merci rig naturellement chacun comprend
je ne peux pas répondre à toutes les
questions
d'abord n'hésitez pas à donner votre
sentiment sur ce qu'on a bien fait on a
mal fait quand vous prenez la parole
c'est pas forcément pour poser une
question
ça peut être aussi pour affirmer une
volonté il ya eu deux ou trois questions
très politique qui ont été posées il ya
d'abord la question du front national je
vous ferai des propositions demain mais
béatrice nous dit comment les faire
revenir
d'abord on les fait revenir en leur
disant qu'on va pas leur reprocher de
nous avoir quittés parce qu'ils ont été
déçus par nous si on commence par
insulter ou part reproché un français
qui votaient pour nous qui n'a pu voter
pour nous
comment voulez vous qu'on le récupère et
béatrice les choses sont claires dans
mon esprit je ferais trancher cela ceux
qui nous ont quittés un moment donné
pour le front national qui veulent
revenir auront toute leur place dans le
cadre des primaires
ces primaires sont ouverts pas
simplement à la gauche et aussi à ceux
qui étaient avec nous et qui nous ont
quittés ou alors cela voudrait dire
qu'il ya deux catégories de citoyens
ceux qui ont droit de voter ce qu'ont à
qui on refuse de droit de voter il ya un
autre débat que nous mènerons là dessus
certains d'entre nous et c'est leur
droit
considère que le front national est un
tel problème qu'il faut s'allier avec
les socialistes contre le front national
moi je considère que je ne veux pas du
front national et que je ne veux pas non
plus de ceux qui font monter le front
national c'est à dire la gauche c'est un
débat que nous auront à trancher
ce n'est pas un débat négligeable ce
n'est pas un débat anecdotique faudra
qu'on l'ait est ce que notre opposition
totale au front national
justifie que nous fassions alliance avec
la gauche
moi je pense que si on fait alliance
avec la gauche on ouvre un boulevard au
front national et que c'est donc
exactement le contraire qui convient de
faire mais on aura en débattre je crois
que c'est une interlocutrice qui a dit
pourquoi les politiques n'ont pas réagi
à l'islamisation
alors qu'il me soit permis quand même de
demander à chacun de réfléchir à ce
qu'on a fait qui le premier a demandé
l'interdiction du voile à l'école si ce
n'est jacques chirac qui est des nôtres
c'est jacques chirac qui a porté le
premier la volonté d'interdire le voile
à l'école et qui madame a fait voter une
loi interdisant le voile intégral dans
les rues en france c'est moi lorsque
j'étais président de la république
on peut parfaitement dire que c'est
insuffisant
il ya deux choses qu'on ne peut pas dire
un conte n'a rien fait et 2 c'est quand
même pas nous qui sommes responsables de
l'incapacité du gouvernement actuel à
faire respecter la loi de la république
nous ne sommes pas au pouvoir enfin à
l'ami du médoc qui disait dans le fond
est ce que avec les primaires qui arrive
est-ce qu'il faut pas que tous les
guides délégué de circonscription
comment il a dit impartiale amis du
médoc
les délégués de circonscriptions sont
élus par les adhérents et les militants
les républicains c'est pas une
administration un je veux pas de
délégués de circonscription qui n'ont ni
odeur ni saveur ni opinions ni colonne
vertébrale ni volonté c'est un guichet
ici
le délégué de circonscription il
représente l'état d'esprit des militants
et même dans le médoc
si vous m'aimez n'hésitez pas à le dire
ça serait trop triste
l'impartialité c'est pas les délégués de
circonscription vous êtes élu il faut
bien que vous soyez élu sur un projet
sur une sensibilité la partialité cher
thierry solère elle viendra des
responsables départementaux en charge
d'organiser les primaires l'organisation
des primaires dans vos départements sera
le fait des délégués départementaux qui
eux devront absolument être impartiaux
pas des délégués de circonscription je
veux l'unité je veux le rassemblement du
parti
mes cheveux pas un parti mort un parti
morne imparti triste un parti où il ya
plus de débat un parti il ya plus de
concurrence
un parti où ce qui serait ici on lui
dirait qu est ce que tu préfères tu sais
pas qu'est ce que tu penses tu sais pas
de quoi tu as envie chez pas s'appelait
la politique j'en sais rien non ici
c'est la vie c'est la passion c'est la
politique avec le respect de l'autre
mais avec la passion pour la france qui
doit nous animer l'impartialité c'est
pas ça